when I was the director of the
Shakespeare Theatre in Stratford
Connecticut I was staying at a famous
French teacher named Michelle sent a
nice home and I picked up a copy of
Shakespeare and I I like bread Henry
five now I this is right during the
Vietnamese War and I was opposed to the
war as almost everybody my age was at
the time and and I thought I don't want
to do Henry five my knowledge of Henry
fire was from Laurence Olivier's film
which was a very famous film it was
clearly a nationalistic jingoistic epic
and I got to the first scene of the play
after the chorus does AU from use a fire
and there's the Bishop of Ely in the
Archbishop of Canterbury talking about
how Henry wants to tax them inordinate
Lee and they're going to lose their
lands and some of their wealth so what
can they do to dissuade him or really to
turn his attention away from this I
thought oh my lord this is this is
already extraordinarily powerful thing
where the church is lying to the king to
set him to go to war not for anything
other than their own reasons that for
somebody in their late twenties was
perfect so I said I got to do this play
then I found out other things that Henry
does he kills the French prisoners
against the rules of engagement or when
he kills his best friend Bardolph so I i
did this very Brechtian cynical
production very modern then we lit
candles at the end you know and march to
42nd Street for a candlelight vigil but
I had difficulty I could do all of that
all the tough stuff about hawks and
doves and killing prisoners but when it
came to all the great speeches like say
Crispin Crispian and once more into the
breach dear friends I had to turn them
around in some way and say they were
propaganda how to take all of that
greatness away in order to make my
theory that this was a anti-war
I government flag when I came back to do
it again and I had realized over the
years that the genius of Shakespeare is
not that it's anti-war or pro or anti
government or pro-government but that
the issue of leading a country is the
complicated one perhaps you do things in
order to for the country that are
somewhat shady perhaps you do things
that are against you because you know
it's better for though you can be heroic
and you can be shallow you can be
idealistic and yet still have some
cynicism you can be all of these things
in a rounded character so I I did almost
the same physical production four years
later except my emphasis was on the
contradictions in Henry you know you can
you can do a lot of what you want with
Shakespeare but I like to suggest the
directors that Shakespeare his thought
is what wider and richer than our own
because Shakespeare doesn't have a moral
point of view he is imminently
reinterpret about by generation after
generation or century after century and
it's right to do so the plays are there
to be looked at a fresh each time